man the last two years has
completely eroded and annihilated any
sense of trust that i have not only in
mainstream media but also in
institutions and the powers that be like
it's just a a
really lethal cocktail of
neglect
malice and incompetence
like all sort of swirled together but
is there still a swath of people that
have faith
in
these mainstream media and is it the
older generation that pretty soon are
going to you know within a couple of
decades and maybe not going to be there
anymore and we're now going to have
no
institutions no uh media that mainstream
media that the people that are coming
through are prepared to trust
it seems to me there's the older
generation that is more skeptical of the
institutions at the moment
uh the sort of radicalized boomers who
are voting for brexit and trump
who are just like you know what no this
is [ __ ] i don't like this we're
getting out you know
eject um and that that seems to me that
the the the and
god bless they're the ones who did the
right thing the problem i have are the
zoomers and the millennials who don't
know any different and don't have any
framework for legitimacy outside of
the power of the state and the
institution
this is this is the worst thing about
intersectionality
and what it's done having proliferated
through our schools and through our
cultures and through our institutions
i'm not sure what we could say it's
proliferated through the schools yet you
know oh it absolutely has i mean might
have got to the stage
oh yeah these people are adults now
i've i've had to have these
conversations with my 11 year old
daughter where she's come home but like
i think i'm bi it's like
what oh well i'm really worried you know
i'm part of the lgbt community i'm
really worried about transphobia she's
11. you know they it's it's everywhere
it is everywhere and this is not
something that we can take lightly
because one problem that we have is that
the entire thing is based on the worship
of power the you can't define anything
without power like racism is power plus
privilege you know blah blah blah blah
power is a component of everything that
they conceive of and if you are
expressly critiquing power relations and
saying if there is a power imbalance
then there is oppression and therefore
this is illegitimate then you have made
illegitimate the relationship between
mothers and daughters fathers and sons
you know between teachers and students
between the prime minister or the
president and the population you know if
all of these become illegitimate then
why would i uphold any of them you know
it's all about the and
the
and if the only legitimating factor is
the raw exercise of power and if that's
literally again we've flattened it down
to just the material so there's not it's
not that we've got an obligation to
these people and they have obligations
to us which is how you spend like the
feudal view of the world as in the king
had an obligation to his subjects you
can go go go read like robin hood poems
and stuff like this
the problem with king john is not
any one thing but it's the fact that his
interests and his obligations are not
being met as the king and this is like
robin hood is a deeply reactionary story
like he's not a revolutionary he's not a
socialist what he's saying is the king
is not obligated he's not upholding his
obligations to the peasants in uh in a
in a loving way he's not acting like
their father you know
and
so
if we've if we've annihilated all of
that and reduced it down to purely the
material exercise of power then great
okay now what legitimizes anything well
it's strength you know that's it and if
generations are coming up who don't
understand that there are moral factors
outside of the pure exercise of power
then all they'll consider to be true is
strength power that's the very beating
heart of fascism that's what the
fascists believe that the state is a god
that creates the civilization under it
and imbues the civilization with its
rights and so in fact this is a great
point i wanted to bring up with you like
what's a human right
define a human right where do they come
from what are they anchored in right and
it seems
[ __ ] nothing
and you can tell this by people like
jeremy corbyn who like broadband is a
human right
what does that [ __ ] mean did he say
that yes yes jeremy corbyn quote
broadband is a human right
what does that mean what does it [ __ ]
mean food water shelter health care none
of these things are huge you're missing
broadband off the bottom of maslow's
hierarchy of needs
absolutely it's the very basic need you
know below
shelter and food and water broadcasting
i mean
what are you gonna do without it right
but seriously he said this and it's just
like okay what the [ __ ] are you talking
about when you say a human right you
know it seems to be whatever's in the
front of his mind at the time as a human
right and it's the same with bernie
sanders than any of these communists
because essentially they take the same
position that's like human rights are
constructed by the power structures they
are whatever the people in charge say
they are therefore put the socialist in
charge and he will say that
housing food and water and broadband is
all human rights and you'll be given all
of these things by the state
like the state was [ __ ] god and it's
like okay i don't really believe in
human rights as this conception of it uh
there are other views on rights but they
aren't you know like this uh you know i
believe in negative rights where they're
in imbued in us by nature because i'm
not religious and i don't think it was
god but uh but this is a different
conversation we're in a different
paradigm now and all of these young
people have been
brought up to believe that health care
can be a human right that food can be a
human right the shelter can be a human
right so there is no
moral there is no intellectual
legitimate you know it means nothing
human rights are whatever we say they
are and that means essentially the party
is always right
that's the problem and this is deeply
concerning i don't think there's any
hope for liberty while we allow these
people to control the discourse and
things i don't even know how we can go
start invalidating almost everything
that was done under these auspices like
that healthcare is a human right it's
not
end of conversation it is an entitlement
i learned this really interesting
insight about ideological beliefs
recently talking about ideologies so the
usefulness of an absurd ideological
belief
is a form of tribal signaling it signals
that the ideology is more important to
the person than reason itself it's a
display of loyalty to your allies and a
threat display to your enemies it's not
about what's true
it's about how does this make me look to
my tribal in-group and out-group so it's
the commodification of beliefs as well
and one of the things that i thought
that was really interesting there is it
becomes almost like a badge of honor
sometimes to hold increasingly extreme
and absurd beliefs and this happens on
both sides i don't think that this is in
any way
unique to one side or another and um
yeah i just thought that that was really
interesting that you wear your beliefs
ideas it's about
yeah well no no you're absolutely right
because if you think about it like
they're holding to a set of again this
this lattice of ideas but that doesn't
what's that got to do with the world
like that's not reality that's a set of
ideas they're put together and said
right this is important and now the
closer i adhere to these ideas
the more
morally correct i am the more
politically correct i am but reality has
been left far behind here reality might
not reflect these ideas at all uh and so
you get absolute lunatic takes that got
nothing to do with the real world being
lauded on places like twitter as being
perfect as being good as being the the
the height of prestige
and the thing is what has this person
done
i've claimed a really extreme position
that you know fits in with this lattice
of ideas
okay
how much effort was that you know how
how much sweat and tears and toil was it
for you to achieve
this
moral virtue that is
saying something really extreme you know
you didn't build a house you didn't
climb a mountain you didn't raise a
child you didn't construct a building
you you said something on the internet
you know it's amazing that that gives
people cred so roll it forward for me
mainstream media what do you think the
future has in store oh um oh god the
main the
the problem they have is people like joe
rogan
who wildly popular i i learned the other
day that joe rogan's audience is about
24 years old on average which is not
good for them but it is good for
everyone else because joe rogan is a
decent human being and he is a human
being for a start you know he's not just
a liar um
it's not good it's especially not good
for left-wing media you get people like
uh tucker carlson and the fox news is
the
the majority of the old mainstream media
at this point it's pretty much the only
game on the right by plays
oh yeah by by view count yeah
um
like by by people tuning into their
shows but they're they're bound to be an
older audience you know joe's is quite a
young audience but um no it's not good
and the thing is i i i you don't want to
make like hard and fast predictions but
we're seeing just a constant decline in
viewership i mean cnn apparently after
trump left it wasn't the stat that was
going around like they'd lost 90 percent
of their audience i don't know and it's
oh well i i i saw one that was 40 and
one was 90. so we'll get from the 90s it
sounds more extreme uh no i but they've
lost a huge chunk of their audience and
it's because what who are they serving
you know who are they serving they're
they're not serving the actual interests
and needs of the people who they want to
watch whereas someone like joe rogan is
you know someone like you are someone
like mia you know we're
talking about things that might help
those people rather than trying to
enforce an institutional gated narrative
where it's like look the powers that be
want you to believe this thing believe
it
what's my investment you know why would
i care why would i want to watch it and
i don't think they know that that's what
they're doing and i don't think they
know how to escape this paradigm they
don't serve anyone other than the
institutions themselves and so the
people who are deeply invested in
left-wing politics and the preservation
of the institutions will watch them and
support them
but everyone else is just getting on
with their lives is just not going to
bother and so
i don't know what else we can really do
other than enjoy the ride as they
continue to fail
but you know i don't i don't think they
can
maintain themselves indefinitely on this
trajectory what's happening people if
you enjoyed that then press here for the
full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace